good morning Millennials
good morning millenials happy Monday
sad Monday - contradiction happy Monday
gassy Monday everything I see everything
what from all your groceries oh my god I
didn't order in once this week weekend
which is crazy because usually I'll
order in like four or five times per
weekend like breakfast lunch dinner no
not per day per weekend I didn't order
and once because I had so many groceries
from which to eat things in which to
snack and you still have groceries yes
yes of course
oh so you're doing so good just
equitable division of assets so you're
pro grocery or pro sorry I'm pro sorry
for sure that's great to know
except I found that I was eating more
because I had what to eat but I think he
might have been eating healthier like
you said you made a box of pasta which
is like it definitely was more healthy
than ordering pasta with all of their
trans fats you know I don't know if
that's necessarily true the way you make
it like you use the less ingredients
probably than a restaurant okay so it
all comes out in the wash sister amen to
that I'm excited about this new way of
life for you well this is the morning
toast and it's great it really is that's
what I really that's what that's what
I've heard
yeah no you know I've never been able to
watch the toast like as a consumer and
I'm so jealous of those that do I always
say like I'm jealous of the people who
get to be friends with me because I'm
amazing no but and also like even if
like you're guest hosting with someone
or I'm guessing it's not the same we
know how the sauce is made we know that
it's treacherous like you guys just got
to enjoy scot-free living a life Riley
like some of you actually think this is
champagne and then an 11th but then at
11:30 they have to like go back to Sally
in the water and like we had to scurry
on out of here so what so many things to
discuss the first is that we have a very
very exciting like very prestigious
announcement I don't think we've even
spoken together and it's me about how
prestigious this is yeah because you
took a while to confirm but now it is
confirmed we are recording they said I
can't say we are recording this
afternoon a podcast only episode because
she's not in New York with here I'll
give you a clip will - charades I mean
okay - rates wait let's wait for the
people to guess okay
house no no charades oh sorry movie
three words
second word lean puck pucker kiss third
word sounds like tooth kiss tooth the
kissing oh we have Joey King also known
as Elle Elle what's her I don't know it
doesn't Holly or Shelly yeah
Elle from the kissing booth also knows
Joey King also known as Mises from
Ramona and Beezus is going to be joining
us as an audio podcast today it's gonna
be extremely late um I don't know maybe
we'll tease the episode like I don't
know if we should release it the day we
record it like maybe no cuz we're I'm
we're not going to work for it yeah I
agree I'm really excited I'm she's like
a secret toaster a so Sturm I have a lot
of questions for her and I'm sure you
all do too so put them in the feed but
really like this is just our opportunity
to fangirl and get some like inside
scoop on the movie that I'm sure we're
all looking forward to I couldn't agree
more I'm very excited everyone's talking
about this new movie on Netflix called
set it up okay that'll call the set up
whatever everyone's been telling me to
watch it and I watch the trailer and
they're like it's the new kissing booth
but like here's the thing I like the
kissing booth I don't want to replace it
and I find some joys to be like
insufferable oh my god I love her oh the
entire Academy is one of them that I
just found out she comes from a famous
family so it's like she's knocked that
even good of an actress but like of
course she's famous you know oh I really
like her and I love Glen Powell
I love holy like a becoming part of my
list of like rotating somebody crushes
so I went on the trip with Glen Powell
and I didn't even know he was famous
like everyone's I could scleral I'm like
who he doesn't like the name Glen Powell
doesn't sound is literally like a
Broadway producer from the 1930s
no and he let empower Big Time magazine
it he also looks like the guy from
Ferris Bueller's Day Off like the friend
who drove that self exactly and like
he's just trad Brad well and John Glenn
from hidden figures in Chad Radwell from
scream queens
sure
Chadwell so I will watch it but like I'm
still in the kissing booth like
infatuation phase and I'm not gonna stop
watching it and to me nothing can be as
good as the kissing booth but why can't
we just have two good movies on Netflix
like finally Netflix serving up premium
content speaking of which Vanessa
Hudgens announced that she is ending
Netflix Christmas film called the
Christmas switch where she's like you
marries a prince at the end and I'm so
excited I thought it was a hallmark
movie it's on no it's Netflix it's
Netflix its hallmark style Netflix movie
just like the Christmas prints oh but
they're filming a sequel to drama drama
speaking of drama I have been following
my sister's footsteps and rewatching Sex
in the City and I would say I'm about to
hit season 1 oh yeah they just were
gonna go to st. Barths and she said no
big mistake
but here's the thing I'm watching like I
said I used to watch like episodes out
of order I mean not as a kid like not as
an adult woman with like I'm a chair
outlook on life just as like a kid and
now as someone who's had a relationship
is married I'm somewhat of an expert
like it's very clear that like I'm not
surprised whatsoever that they wanted
nothing to do with her she was a
nightmare monster she did everything
wrong she's supposed to be a dating
expert her going to church when the mom
is there and then like going and
introducing herself to the mom I'm
Carrie Carrie Carrie like she doesn't
know who you are he's a 50-year old man
he doesn't tell his mom everything wait
it gets worse the part okay it wasn't a
big deal
but she made it such a big deal and like
she kept projecting like her own
insecurities onto him like right like
you had this perfect life like he does
it he's just a normal guy and you think
that and you're insecure so you're
making yourself like being naggy you
know I agree
wait and even like this like the key and
the apartment like and her leaving her
stuff there it's just so crazy because
when you watch down the line like when
Aiden when she's eating Aiden even gives
her quiche Nick freaks out she's like
she turned tonight she doesn't want to
get married right and just who are you
like what kind of who are you know she's
like doing like he is going he's the
anti-big and and she can't handle that
either like what do you want [ __ ] you
know and just like strictly just
restricted to the big relationship just
as like a third party perspective like
she is doing everything wrong like you
want to land the rich cool old
like you don't act like this like you
act like a human being adult not like a
child like just like watching all the
things oh when she she gets drunk and
goes to watch him he's watching the
fight
uh-huh and she's a climbing oh my god
I'm like sucking his cheeks like that's
not what adults ooh okay she was just
driving me nuts and the whole thing is
like their their love story is like one
that got away like almost meet and then
finally the end I could Suzanne
chuckling Suzanne Somers novel whatever
that girl said that's not it
she lost him because she was a [ __ ]
nightmare yeah and their curly hair yeah
but then like throughout the season he
gets like less stable too so then they
start to make more sense for each other
but after sees him on like she's just
straight-up not good enough for him
night next and that's what it comes down
to oh and she's calling him when she's
with Justin Theroux like I'm a Jared say
hi Jared hi that was Jared like cut it
up she's horrible minion the part what's
so crazy is that season one like she's
not even that bad like if you know so
much more I don't think I can watch it
we're watching season five in Nashville
like we were gonna throw stuff at the TV
you don't even feel that way in season
one and you still hate her
she's just like she's so unreasonable
she's such a child like oh my god it
drives me nuts
yeah and and the older she gets more
child as she gets with her tutus like
she's so crazy her being a child in
Paris I'll never forget I'm sorry I know
you know when I commuted me Miranda the
goat when she was sitting at the baby
shower she was like the more the more I
think about it the more I think the
woman from Hansel and Gretel is
misunderstood like she built her dream
house and these kids just came started
to eat I just think like her perspective
is us I'm surprised she can stand Carrie
I'm surprised that they're the two best
friends what bothers me is that like the
friendship of the four of them doesn't
really exist without Carrie and that's
still not how it be Carrie is like the
inseparable friend who only talks about
herself
oh yeah like and like up for me Samantha
is well I love Samantha Charlotte I
can't distinguish who I like more but if
I only had to watch one of them it would
be Samantha just cuz she's so in fact
but like Samantha and Miranda should be
kickin it left and right like
funny they both are realistic they get
totally agree and the fact that these
girls only hang out one-on-one was
Carrie and not each other and then like
Miranda and Charlotte have beef later on
and like yeah Charlotte is the man to
have beef yeah because there's my
different she would have been way more
dynamic if we got to see like other
friendships starting to blossom and also
like if we saw the three of them get
together and like hot [ __ ] bad Carrie
that's right the only time it really
started is realistic is after Carrie's
breakup with the big I don't know if he
I think it's in the next season like
she's talking about it so much of her
friends are like you need to go see a
therapist because we can't listen to you
talk about this anymore oh oh so when
she goes out with the new Yankee like oh
my god she's so annoying like the new
Yankees it's hotter than big like be
happy right and when you're like with
the new Yankee and you see big like you
should be so happy you won like yeah and
it's impossible for you to win because
you're you and he's him but he found a
way when she's running around in a big
fur coat and the little dresses like I
want to take that code and strangle her
with it I think I know which one it
could be fur brown one yeah well her
it's just it's I can write a whole
dissertation before on trouble is wrong
with sex in the city and by the way
someone should I'm sure someone has but
let's it's time to re-up Before we jump
in to the fast five stories that you
need to know before you take a bite out
of your morning toast which we will we
also have a very special guest today
someone who is a celebrity in her own
right but is also a toaster and that's a
great thing about the choices that we
never would have known if it weren't for
our world famous Facebook group that we
had a celebrity amongst our clientele
amongst our ranks amongst our ranks if
you guys remember the movie the clique
which of course you do because it's an
iconic movie and really molded me as a
woman and also it's in a kind of novel
and of course series a novel series we
have Ellen Marlowe here as I say Ellen
Pompeo Ellen Marlowe who played Claire
Lyons in the movie The Clique which was
produced by Tara Biggs
she'll be joining us a little bit later
she's brought along some
behind-the-scenes photos from the set
and they're everything change honestly
it's too much like they are so before
their time but look here we we have one
I was her and her little green ensemble
that's Claire on set and her Juicy
Couture hami down shirt obviously from
Massey's throwaway then okay
actually recently watch that movie with
Mario and like it's so cringy like and
it's so funny because when we were kids
we didn't think that was cringy we
thought that was cool
like everything what did she say like
tonight invite you to my BB q couleur
cuz you're all up in my grill like if
anyone said that today like you would be
shot no but we also need to but the book
themselves were so good we need to find
out like where where's the follow-up
like this was supposed to be a series we
hire banks really dropped the ball
you can you follow up how was your
doctor appointment with dr. sherry easy
you guys that's what I mean to rush out
on Friday because we got an appointment
with Ramona singers plastic surgeon dr.
sheldon DZ and i don't know if you know
but I'm so not confused today like I
know what's going on okay so it's like
my face doesn't have the urge to make
that face anymore which is so lovely
well that's and then if I try to make
that face I get a little bit of pushback
if I try really hard I don't want to
break the Botox you know so I totally
know you look great so we've been
together Sharon Gacy said I didn't
really need it but she did offer up like
a hollow jury list of other things that
I need I'm going back on Wednesday for
weird is really not gonna do she said I
didn't eat it really no I trust sharing
easy I just love the feeling and I don't
know what's happening out there and I
just love how every time I see Sharon
easy I think of Serengeti and I don't
even know what that is but it sounds
really similar okay
I was a insta light but where she said
it's like where a patient procedure just
like you it's a cryo but the opposite
and we're just gonna shed inches she
said you can lose up to 16 inches little
more I thought about that it's like I
thought it was 16 inches like around one
place no it's like do I lose an inch of
my toe like it counts to this photo okay
I was thinking about the ex I was
explaining it to Ben and Ben is like
you're getting liposuction but I'm like
no it's big
no but it's real it's insta lipo's it's
like like it's like go for Instagram
it's a diet lipo lipo for the Instagram
joke yeah era exactly
anyways we're all aboard the plastic
surgery train oh my god once I went like
I was like I see how people get addicted
like she was showing me all the
different procedures and I'm like
there's definitely a couple in here that
I need and I just think it's good to
start young and I'm really excited like
I'm I want to be like I want to have
like Jocelyn Wildenstein face stop
because and also like that's
stereotype that like plastic surgery or
Botox comes along with it I feel like so
many people don't know that Botox is
like a very normal thing that people do
yeah I saw it in the toasters there was
like a debate going on between people
who are like worried that I got Botox
and I was gonna turn into Jocelyn
Wildenstein anyways he takes so much
money to look like that yeah don't worry
the show is not generating that much
revenue so will always maintain somewhat
a resemblance of ourselves unfortunately
as long as this show stays under the
radar like it is we'll be fine exactly
okay are you ready to jump into the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast because Loki a lot
happened this weekend okay first of all
breaking this morning breaking this
morning
wait and before I say this I got a bunch
of tweet speak of people being like
please say you're not gonna talk about
the bachelor in paradise spoilers People
magazine spoiled it here's work I'm
gonna talk about it what no it's not
because it's not a spoiler that's the
difference when People magazine gets a
photo and they write it up that means
the bachelor production company gave it
to them
that means bachelor wants people to know
they're trying to promote this new
season of bachelor in paradise so it's
not a spoiler there's no way to avoid it
so well this is a no spoiler zone like
I'm pretty sure I know who wins the
Bachelorette right now as I say it but
we all know that Colton does not win and
he's in paradise during a future
circulation Romancing TM that's not a
spoiler but that's intentionally
released by production because they want
to create hype so please don't say that
we're spoiling stuff because we're not
there's a difference between a spoiler
and like a promotion right and now so
much drama has spun off of that because
Colton and Tia are smooching in paradise
and by the way I'm like so here for it
and Raven and Becca were fighting on
Twitter obviously Rebecca Martina
Martinez whom I despise who was like
trying to have Becca what's her last
name Joe Frank who friends back even
though she was like shading her in
previous tweets cuz she's just like a
meat and girl and just like so no she's
like once Twitter followers she's
bothering me so much and like I like
that Raven took her on but like I didn't
even want her to give her the time of
day I would like Raven getting her hands
dirty with this like she's so above it
but she's just a good friend she could
Taylor yep okay let's start from the
beginning because he is not home with a
phone to defend herself right and Raven
is like you can rot in hell yeah right
now
bachelor in paradise is a she I and
Jared hymen are engaged you guys letting
each in flats which is so crazy because
she was on the beach
more I look at this picture like there
are so many thoughts that I have but
first here is the story only happy tears
here reports People magazine as she I
end Jared hi bond are engaged people
confirms high bond popped the question
Sunday while in Mexico for the upcoming
fifth season a bachelor in paradise the
summer spin-off series where The
Bachelor lumps up and down relationships
began three years ago hi bond got down
on one knee on the beach is the
bride-to-be wearing a bright yellow
dress put her hands on her trust and
threw her head back in excitement okay
her reaction is really like so sweet and
genuine and I'm actually happy for abotu
after zooming in on her face like that
is a cha-ching show us the ring show us
the ring um I really I as much as
everything that they do is so
predictable
I really did not see this coming oh I
kind of did like I just figured if they
were gonna get engaged or like have some
sort of nuptial something they would
find a way to get it on TV and I did I
just didn't think it would be this soon
because everything else about their
relationship has kind of been like
realistic you know being friends for so
long and then finally jumping into a
relationship I thought they might
actually take their time but no this is
about your world I really need not you
know I thought slash still hold out hope
that Adam and Raven are gonna get
engaged in paradise because that's where
they met and it's been a year now yeah
and they have like the most normal
really and I think they're moving she's
moving to Dallas or so I thought you
moved really I can't keep up but yeah
where she lives there another time and
like still has the house and Roxy
exactly I don't know what's going on but
I I was hoping that they were gonna
beach but paradise is so confident I
think paradise is such a better show
than the regular season like I get that
we have to have the regular season in
order to have it we're gonna get like
people but I just love paradise I think
it's such a better show it's so much
more enjoyable to watch so I'm really
looking forward to this season of
bachelor in paradise it looks juicy a
Tesla geez I can't believe that like
after all this network has been through
they're still shooting the show I am
this time last year when we were being
investigative journalists when we like
we really earned our is yeah anyways so
you're just flies it's that it's really
crazy but Colton and Tia we're seen on a
date in Mexico yeah and then every I
guess more stuff is gonna happen with
Colton maybe tli goes back to Becca and
says I actually do have feelings for him
but like this is television you guys
ever
one who's on the show is there for a
purpose Colton and Tia had this master
plan to get to Paradise together like
honestly good for them no I'm so here
for it I love Bala talk [ __ ] I love both
of them supposed to see them together
and we know that Beca is happily ever
after we know that she's engaged it's a
win for everyone
totally I hate when people who are on
the show and very much know how
superficial and like fake it is start
complaining like throwing shade about
other scenarios that don't involve them
that are so clearly made-for-tv like no
[ __ ] it's a TV show you were on it you
made it to the final whatever for three
I know how fake it is like you're fake
to stop calling out other people that's
just hypocritical of you and then like
you put them in a position to not be
able to say anything cuz like obviously
it's fake right perfectly kind of their
argument like I hate when people on the
show we're like oh I just I find it
really difficult to be in this type of
scenario like where are you dating other
men like so don't sign up do you know
that this is what it is right
like there's no answer for that right
because this is just what is it you guys
had to suspend reality yeah and that's
just like an unfair argument to say like
that they're they're sleuthing for TV
everyone is right and at least they're
giving us a good story out of it some of
the other suits for TV like our big were
like that girl Samantha when she was
doing that kind of Twitter paradise like
four years ago Samantha and Joe yeah
just his first man then Joe you guys I
was doing what everyone else was doing
but she just got called out and she was
doing what bachelor in paradise is made
on now it she's people messaging before
the show having relationships meeting in
Paradise and seeing what happens yeah
anyways well she goes before her time to
Jared hi Boehm and Ashley I'm kinetic
she's gonna be Ashley high but I'm sure
they'll get married in Paradise in a
year on to their yeah we're like on a
podcast episode yeah honestly
congratulations to them for making
French happen because I took really long
time and you know what hard work pays
off I think that's the message here
mm-hmm don't give up on your dreams and
I was reading like eanes posted the
engagement problematic you caption and
they had a key caption but I was reading
all the comments and it's like it's
really negative no I was seeing like a
she can get engage in there's hope for
me to like I think this motors been
sitting here for a month what it's fine
I think as long as it's not in the
sunlight okay next up back to our
favorite buyer who do you think is our
favorite person to talk about on the
show recently aren't around and Pete
Davidson but in general
Sarah Jessica Parker like now Oh Khloe
Kardashian no give me give me like
charades okay um I like okay mega Markel
yeah okay so next up in the megan
markle's howitzers are gonna be so
confused I just put a fake crown on my
head and Claudia gasps Megan Markham do
you see mama sparkles interview that and
her latest outfit latest outfit of the
blue on the blue and white are Zombo
yeah the blue max really loves well he
max he went a little above the ankles I
believe it's called MIDI lovely and no I
didn't see Thomas Merkel Thurston it up
on TV What did he say
Meagan Marcos dad says she cried over
the news he'd missed the Royal Wedding
they were disappointed quote Meagan
Marcos father says she was very
emotional when he told her when he told
her and Prince Harry that he wouldn't be
able to walk her down the aisle on her
wedding day in May in an interview with
the UK's good morning Britain early
Monday Tom um Pierce Pierce Morgan's
[ __ ] all comes back to Piers Morgan
Thomas Markel said quote they were
disappointed Megan cried I'm sure she
did cry and they both said take care of
yourself we are really worried about you
they said the important thing is that I
get better well it seems like he's
better enough to be on good morning
Britain right the days leading up to the
world running on May 19th were filled
with unexpected family chopped him up
for Megan Thomas initially decided to
attend the wedding after his arrangement
with the paparazzi to stage several
photo shoots we all know this so babies
all the details thoroughly on the first
time since his big scandal and since
missing the Royal Wedding that he's been
on TV and he's very well behaved it's
like you know the Queen is paying for a
media trainer because he did a good job
and I just I do want a little bit of
justice for my gamer know cuz I Megan
Michaels dad cuz I think he's
misunderstood I think he is too but
there's a lot that we don't know with
him and the mom yeah that I was reading
about like his family's like super
racist or something like that I'm not
100% sure I can't cast aspersions
actually I take that back but there's
there's some shady racism something
something well I don't know whatever
justice for the mom Jess yeah well she I
think she should serve dad knows this
for herself like out she was the picture
of guys right she was a portrait of
elegance exactly and I just like it's
it's the whole thing is sad but what's
not sad is that Megan Markel is the
Duchess of sexy
and she's killing it that's just a
suffix that's just sub sex sex sex sex
that should be her Instagram bio I hate
that the Royals kind of instagrams um
the world like at the royal family has
an Instagram and Princess Eugenie and
had like two palaces a Kitty Spencer
have one I don't know but she she needs
once you get somebody she crushes it
Kitty Spencer has the best style of the
whole world family cuz apparently there
was another royal wedding she was she
was best dressed again again again it
just must be nice stuff just disposable
money just like buy clothes and just
like keep going to weddings yeah I like
never go to buy these weddings cuz I
didn't nobody to mine that's both things
that you just said aren't true you got
in buy these weddings all the time and
you never want to go that's true and
then like you invited less people to
yours so that you wouldn't get invited
to less weddings honestly though like
even if you're like my best friend or
like even like you like I [ __ ] hate
weddings even my own wedding I hate it
that's true like it just seems like a
party designed for never-ending torture
I like weddings oh my god I just I
[ __ ] hate them
like between like the obligation to like
stand and dance and like no one ever
eats like it's just oh I disagree I feel
like there's so much time to eat and
there's so much time to dance it's like
activity it's like camp and it's all
planned out for you and it's great it's
like you eat then you have your 20
minute digestive period while there's
like speeches and like the first dance
and then you get to dance the night away
to like great songs if done right well
actually it depends on the type of
wedding that's true because most of the
wedding's I go to are like Orthodox and
then really have speeches like it's all
just like dance dance dance and it's
just like I'm tired
well thanks see my dancing the whole
time yeah that's Tim that's not what I
think about when I think about like
that's what I traditional thing about
weddings like oh I think of ceremony
pretty
sit down eat and then dance the night
away you know so Jewish weddings like
religious weddings are so much longer
because they have like tissue jack and
then the ceremony and like then the
Simca dancing and then the wedding
started is such good food yeah that's
true
assuming you can make it on time and
then you're not so hungry when you get
into the reception that's kind of nice
then you're not like one-track minded
like waiting for the food to come that's
always the worst when you're just like
go to a wedding just to eat and there's
no food I love to eat are you ready for
the next story why wouldn't I be oh you
know what I've been spoken about this in
a while so you're not ready tickets to
my show the dirty jeans store are
available
calm Rolly Philly Phoenix Palm Beach
Denver st. Louis and Boston in DC coming
soon
that's exciting it what's new with the
dirty jeans tour any new updates for us
I made a poster I saw it's fantastic it
still has some kinks because like I said
I'm adding a show in Boston I don't have
a confirmed date yet but the Boston show
is like I really need I know that the
boss Dean's you know more than I'm one
podcast in Massachusetts so the Boston
show is it could be like a big deal for
my career like I'm not joking like
actually Wow so it's at a prestigious
theater some wood some would compare it
to the Beacon Theatre here in New York
some I'm not I'm not saying I would with
someone so if I could like even come
close to selling it out it would be like
a really big deal so I knew the boss
Dean's to come out strong and for every
boss Dean they need to buy three tickets
each um so you'll buy you'll keep us
posted I'm we can buy them I'll buy my
own ticket
I will come to Boston yes of course it's
been a while its own I haven't seen the
Liberty Bell in the very Bell is in
Boston Philly I haven't seen the tea
party in quite some time
the Boston Tea Party I haven't seen
Nicolas Cage and quite some time we
should have to Boston I haven't seen
Fenway Park in quite some time
Independence Hall that's in Philly -
honestly Boston and Philly are the same
no but like there goes dark all we both
took trips in like the middle middle
school to each of them uh-huh they're
both rich in American history but to
like Nicholas Cage has spent a lot of
German both of them that people there
are so different like right Philly
absolute terrorists and Boston and I'm
getting Eagles fans are good people but
they're both likes I get there was such
strong characters but there are
strengths there they're fighting for
differences playbook is about Philly
yeah but then like that movie about like
Jimmy Fallon being obsessed with the
baseball team's fever pitch she is about
Boston and then also Legally Blonde like
she gets married offend my Park Boston
and she's up getting married at Fenway
Park though no cuz she brought the movie
today see she brought the BC is also
really similar no but DC is no DC is the
nation's capital Churchill like doesn't
have teeth let ik teams who they don't
have like they do
Maryland Orioles Washington Nationals
they're from the DC though and they also
have the Wizards even though I think
that's the other Washington and Maryland
is that okay DC is a state no city in
Maryland Virginia where it's like
between Virginia and Maryland but like
it's in its own state it's very
confusing I don't know what it's
categorized as it's um I forget what the
word is but it's very confusing
I think it's American this is it like a
normal question okay whatever anyways
moving on housewives say Bravo keeps the
booze flowin oh a BB dresser dresser who
starred on season five and six of the
Real Housewives of New York said the
show's production team could sometimes
go too far with their eagerness to
liquor up the cast she recalled the time
a producer phoned ahead of filming and
asked her to take a shot of alcohol with
cast meet Ramona Singer during a
reconciliation scene at a restaurant I
told the head producer I don't want to
do a shot can you just fill it with
water said Josh r-47 who grew up with an
alcoholic mother and says she never
taken a shot before and they said no I
was so weak and so intimidated by the
production team and I just gone through
all the negotiations of my contract for
the second season and those were
demoralizing she said I took the shot I
felt tremendous pressure to do it she's
hardly the only new Housewives star
who's had a problem with alcohol served
while being filming on may 9th episode
of Bravo's her honey
during the medley showed up to dinner
seemingly wasted slurring her words and
picking a fight with the Puerto Rico
hurricane relief team she was dining
with in Miami after disinviting medley
to Puerto Rico medleys dinner come
bohemian and casually Bethenny Frankel
had a change of heart but gave her a
stern talking-to during their private
jet ride to the islands what does that
have to do with know that Aviva's claim
I totally agree that's like they're
trying to prove a point and they just
really know and the jorinda was drunk
okay the rest of the article in page six
talks about when Gretchen Rossi got
really drunk that time okay come ready
intentionally saying you want to get her
naked wasted so that's not the same and
here's the thing a new dress sure is an
enormous baby and just we got to see a
glimpse of her insecurities and
craziness while she was on the show so
like we have to take everything we say
through that everything J nothing fake
about me except this so you have to look
at everything she says through that lens
second of all the lens of a leg throw of
a crazy like thrower
second of all I have a hard time
believing that a producer what
call ahead and tell her to take a shot
like well you didn't to producer to son
better think students bring you up and
be like hey Aviva take a shot so stupid
second of all I'm third of all I just
find it interesting people's reactions
to the story because usually when
something like this happens if it were
to be true like if someone accuses
someone of assault like other people
come out of the woodwork and they're
like yes this happened to me too no one
has said it has come backed up Aviva's
claims in fact bethany frankel tweeted
at her saying look like i've been on TV
for 13 years i brought you on the show
and you know that's not the entire
environment it is and Andy Cohen put on
his snapchat story Instagram story it
was on the cover of the New York Post he
was like this is such [ __ ]
slow to say oh and then he was also on
but she's not yeah and like at the end
of it a like her bit herb the claim
she's making is that they force her to
take one shot right that's it's a
reconciliation scene with Ramona like
nothing would even happen escalated if
they were to force her to take a shot it
would be when you're throwing your leg
all over will Cirque right or like on a
group trip and everyone's already hiked
up I'm jet-lagged let's throw some
alcohol into the mix and see what
happens
okay so Beth Delaney who is our resident
journalist she said that I've even did
it on an interview and the interview she
gave was super awful the interviewers
were like kissing her ass being like
yeah tell us more oh my god I could see
her be like extra and kind of like just
playing the victim no and like just
charging up this story because she
thinks like it would be interesting but
I don't think that she realized the
claim that she was making which is that
it's a which is a blanket statement that
Bravo producers pry Wearhouse eyes with
alcohol when I don't think that's true
at all and there's so many like
disgruntled housewives disgruntled ex
cast mates of various Bravo shows that
if that were the case I feel like we
would have heard about it a long time
ago
and if that were the case now that it's
this big news story like other people
would be coming out of the woodwork and
sit like tweeting like you know that you
know Alexis Bellino loves a moment of
fame look she would have tweeted about
it too you know I'm just I'm not buying
it I'm not buying it and if the story
doesn't add up and that's your biggest
claim is that you work forth to take a
shot and the biggest claiming why the 86
article is that they have to back it up
with the fact that during a one-time
showed up drunk to dinner like during
this drinker that's what we know about
her who they're also like showing Kim
Richards and her substance abuse on the
show but like it was before everyone
knew Kim Richards was an alcoholic
before the show and they were all hiding
it during
show what else I don't know apples and
oranges knuckle truly New York apples
Ossie oranges spin-off done apples and
oranges yeah that shed where they all go
to Mexico
totally I thought that we were gonna get
a housewives all-star season so thing
like I the people were talking about it
like the best housewives like Nene Kim
Lisa would love that look at the house I
don't know what they would do maybe they
were going on vacation but it was like
throwing around that's a really good
idea right okay what else what else we
got on the docket for today Kim
Kardashian is back at the justice table
what does she do we know hold on she is
I've got a frozen I know I have so many
tabs open because there was just so much
news I couldn't decide but she is out in
just like that's just a classic morning
show host problem she's on another case
the reality queen tweeted about the
plight of San Quentin prison death row
inmate Kevin Cooper asking California
Governor Edmund Jerry Brown to retest
DNA evidence in his case so now that
she's had success with Alice uh-huh
she's back at the podium and trying to
seek out justice for another wants to
run for president or splaying I read
somewhere like the Train opposed she's
she wouldn't rule it out right the dead
everybody and then the headline is she's
writing her president right so I'm the
Cato here details of the case okay this
person is on death row she tweeted
Governor Brown can you please test the
DNA of Kevin Cooper Cooper 59 was
convicted of the murders of Douglas and
Peggy Ryan their ten-year-old daughter
Jessica and her friend ten-year-old
Chris Hughes in Chino Hills California
1985 since his conviction Cooper has
maintained his innocence and has
exhausted all Appeals for his commission
according to the San Diego Tribune
summer Cooper's advocates argue that the
San Bernardino Sheriff's Department
tampered with DNA evidence to frame
Cooper and that his evidence found on
t-shirt Cooper says he never wore should
be retested hey did your iPad just die
yeah but does that 100% maybe oh here he
couldn't take all them it couldn't take
all the news and it was working really
hard it's also shook by this story as
well no we're back we're back in [ __ ]
I'm so like this is like a really sad
story like a whole family died last
month I know last night senator Kamala
Harris also called on the governor to
allow the DNA to be retested
Governor Brown hasn't announced
decision yet a rep for brown told the
post in a statement Sunday the
governor's office has received the
clemency petition from Cooper and it
remains under review okay like just test
it it takes five seconds and like you
have a lot of money just to it what's
problem it's you know all this red tape
no it's it's great either the test is
positive and we can we can sleep with a
conscious knowing we're killing a
murderer or he go he's vindicated like
either scenario works for me these
things take time
unfortunately that's everything take
time it's like I give everything in five
min of Herman you know it's just like
I'm so sick of all the red tape like
just do stuff like enough where was any
permission like ever oh this takes five
just having business days just like I do
it I'm so done waiting for corporate
America and the justice system like I'm
done making my own justice you know five
to seven businesses could be like ten
days yeah because what if you do it on a
Friday and it's like you do it in the
afternoon you don't see whatever you're
looking for for ten days no I mean I
literally ordered a bag because I have a
planner now and it's 11 inches wide and
like I need a purse like I carry around
my backpack like a [ __ ] two-year-old
everywhere but I think it's time to grow
up because I need to stop ringing my
laptop places I'm running a successful
morning show and I also need my planner
because I'm trying to keep you around
and I'm on tour and it's just like I
need a woman's bag like is enough like a
tote yeah but like not you need a bag
that used to everyday nothing you change
with your outfit right and that you can
also be kind of hard on like like rough
on yes hard on um so I got a bag and I
like Express ship because I was so
excited like if yesterday weren't Sunday
it would have came yesterday it's gonna
come today but like Sunday really it's
like so not only does the government
take forever to do everything nobody
works on Sunday it's like come on that's
really sad they even have to start off a
new week I gotta write like oh and like
I don't know just annoying that's
annoying I think about that and the red
tape surrounding this case just through
the red tape surrounding my mind my
freedom like we're supposed to supposed
to be the free country right and I'm
always being told what not to do it's
[ __ ]
sorry I'm rent over sort of rant oh oh I
just want to say it like a grandpa I'm
glancing over at the comments like
everyone's telling me I look so skinny J
and like
it's just like a Joe and like I see
myself and like I've seen myself every
day the speak like with legs I can't
find the right position for my legs so I
left like chunky legs today that can
everyone stop lying to me no but there
they wouldn't say if it weren't true yes
they would they're just nice girls you
think so I don't think no the common
terms they call us out like I think they
mean it
I kind of facially say nothing I got a
facial yesterday and she walks my lip
without asking but don't you do that in
no it wasn't mad but like first of all I
know that you could do a waxed and if
innovational I mean it makes sense she's
taking care of I found consensual life
yeah you know I just thought it was and
she took me more for it so like it was
just really bizarre my god this is hot
ow
it was interesting that's cool that's
kinda cool then she had seven wanted
eyebrow wax I'm like no it's too
particular yeah they're looking good
there on fleek okay you ready for our
last story before we bring in Kyle lair
Claire Teresa and Joe Giudice almost in
the clear in bankruptcy case oh isn't
this exciting he's not gonna get
deported
I don't know Teresa and Joe Giudice is
bankrupt bankruptcy case is finally
ending a United States bankruptcy judge
dismissed their 2009 case on Friday per
court documents obtained by page six
they aren't totally in the clear yet
though as they still need to pay back
the IRS and the New Jersey Department of
the Treasury but the judge noted that
Teresa has a payment plan secured with
both the Real Housewives of New Jersey
stars were convicted in 2014 of
bankruptcy fraud conspiracy to commit
mail fraud wire fraud and failing to pay
taxes stemming from the bankruptcy the
previous year Teresa and Joe were
indicted and accused of trying to hide
their fortune in the bankruptcy filing
they initially pleaded not guilty to the
charges but eventually changed their
pleas that's so interesting because like
I feel like the way that they're making
reparations they're like paying back all
the money they owe was like from Bravo
and like Teresa's like doing it on her
own cuz like Joe doesn't even have job
no and like she had a new book come out
she's working overtime hard like and I'm
sure she's getting paid hefty amounts
for the for the show for appearing on
the show or else I know she wouldn't be
doing it so it's just funny enough funny
it's like interesting how like Joe got
her into this mess like she's getting
them out I mean she's just a strong nice
woman she needs to like move on from
she's an independent woman babe oh she
really is no but like it's kind of like
if he when he gets out and assuming that
he stays in the country like what an
amazing
that will be for all them they'll highly
get a fresh start and she I'm sure like
she will take him to task
yeah but like this will all be behind
them and like for so much treachery
endured like so much pain so much
sadness like I'm really excited for them
to have a completely new chapter right
but like it's gonna take her a while to
forgive him probably because like she's
still like if ever if yeah and she like
lost time with her mom and right I think
that's what upsets her the most it's
just so sad and I just hope it doesn't
become made sadder by him getting
deported like we have to keep Joe here
so that he can make amends to the
control of keep Joe stateside yeah
that's a sad sad even say it okay we are
about to take a break because when we
return we will be coming back with the
Academy Award winner
Ella Marlowe she played cold air in the
clique she's a toaster and she'll be
joining us so any questions you have for
Claire feel free to leave on the
Facebook or the YouTube stream and we
will get them to her we're very excited
so stay tuned we'll see you in just a
minute
you
we are dock with someone whom we admire
me a who shaped our child really
interrelate please give it up for Ellie
Marlowe but I'm just gonna call you
Claire okay
ha Blair huh with my - flute yes of
course does everyone like do you
understand the scope of the show like
the scale of like how big of a deal the
movie was Oh read the books yes okay and
how did you get the dart okay so my two
best friends from like sixth grade who
now live in the city and we still hang
out like three times a week the three of
us were obsessed with the books we like
assigned ourselves character and whether
Claire I was Alicia oh yeah okay because
Alicia like how good I was Alicia I
think Katie was Massie and I think
Olivia was Kristen I don't remember but
we were like obsessed in the movie like
the breakdown came out and I was acting
like I was in a Broadway show as a child
okay and so I went to LA and I was doing
the whole like auditioning and filming
TV thing and the auditions came out and
I was like I have to be in this movie
and I went in from I went in from a see
first oh really
and then they were like nah - like
you're more of a Claire Claire I was
back it was the wildest audition process
we had I had 40 pages of sides that's
like the script I literally had to learn
40 pages of it and I went back nine
times Wow and they like mixed and
matched us I mean it like to this day
like I'm 24 like and I still edition
like I had three auditions last week
like do craziest audition process
so in she's not bizarre I need to be mr.
BIG's was type 2 which was she have a
photo of you and Tyra
she was the producer okay was she there
every day she you can it took my
brother's like dying she came for one
day what she's there she was at my final
callback so she like made the final you
know check and then she was on set for a
day for EPK so that's like the behind
the scenes like special feature stuff
she came to like film although of course
I actually brought a bag of tricks you
guys are gonna be is a bag of stuff for
us for us so what's in it okay so
obviously Tyra Banks at the time hundred
show huh kiss my fat ass we already ever
and we went on the show to promote the
movie you did we did and it was like the
wildest experience and so all of us were
just so excited to be there like we're
just like we're going on the Tyra show
you know what's gonna happen and
afterwards we did a photo shoot with her
and then we went on our merry way about
a month later all of us get a box you're
so dramatic
it was gonna box it but I mean you're
gonna see a month later we get a box and
truly this is what that is so are you
joking I literally look like an alien's
it says love Tyra it's a picture of the
girl the girls in Tyra and that's
adorable comic say where oh my god
keeping this this whole time okay so the
search for this like when I found out I
was going on the test like this is the
equivalent of like you guys going on
watch what happens live like this is
like the holy grail of talk shows for me
obviously puss here um and so my family
my mom's like oh my god you have to take
the Tyra pillow on the show and I had
completely forgotten about it I turn
around last night I'm like in my family
and I like we all live together the
three of us and I turn around and my
brother is literally standing in the
door like this I'm so glad you found it
I'm gonna take it okay I have so many
questions for you guys cuz this is the
toes hips from driving you to my baby
cam no you guys I watched it last night
I saw your Instagram story okay so I
have so many questions for you like oh
my god gistic alright so the four girls
and you were obviously adversaries in
the film but what was it like were they
nice wheels everyone was there a real
Massey Bach on Ted um yes okay so the
girl who played Massey Elisabeth is like
I've seen her now as like adults and
she's been very very nice I think during
the process of filming she was a little
method
[Laughter]
you know and like
no disrespect like everyone has a
process like I think that's just how she
wanted to go into it so she like
distanced a little bit from me but I had
since seen her like at auditions and
callbacks or whatever she's like
absolutely lovely so sweet so she
treated you like they're not like it
wasn't so extreme but like I was like
very close with the rest of the girls
like I mean we literally had sleepovers
every Friday so we like just he peed
literally we tp'ed our directors hotel
room like toilet papered the whole room
like it was just like it was like summer
camp where did you guys film the movie
Rhode Island Rhode Island University oh
I didn't know that I'm sorry I do know
that but there were like some iconic
cast members in the movie right Liz
Gillies is in it yeah right and the guy
from 13 reasons why he was a woman I
mean clay I don't even you younger
brother did and I watched it last night
and I was like he's a star do you guys
still keep in touch yes he's in a band
and he played a show like less than a
year ago and my mom and I went and saw
him after and everything what kind of
show he's just like in a bad rock band
yeah it's like an indie rock band yeah
they're totally good he's so cute okay I
have a controversial question for you
I'm just curious oh my god take Cher's
Bobby but like how much do they pay you
to be in the movie cuz it was a straight
to DVD movie but it's also an iconic
film so like and based off best selling
best ally what's that a lot like I mean
like I didn't get like a hundred grand
for door I think like it was I just get
like 50 I I think it was like something
in that like range I was 13 I don't
remember so like my mom's like put this
away for later and that's later so I
guess it was something I thought you a
car yeah what kind of I just got a
little Honda nice when I was 18 and you
know actually 24 oh yeah so and now
you're living in New York and you are
working actress I live here I was
actually on tour with the Broadway show
kinky boots okay over a year and that
was an incredible time now I just live
here my brother's a musician and he's
here with me today
and so we write music and we post covers
on YouTube
since all that I'll die say something
anything you want I'd love to you can we
sing something together we can but I
want you to sing to me first
it's my thing to meet Allah why do you
guys sing that song oh my god yes have
you ever seen such a beautiful night
yeah I could almost kiss the stars
they're shining so bright Claudia come
in no you go when I see you smiling I go
oh oh I would never want to miss this
cause in my heart I know what this is
hey now hey now this is what dreams are
made of
Wow hey now hey now that was so good oh
my God thank you
I think they let you sing in the movie I
honestly I don't know and also you were
asking about where the other two were
and we were supposed to do we were
supposed to do three right that was my
next question
the books the books went on forever I
read like all 20th why was there no
second movie I think I ain't like on it
again I was like 13 so like so much was
just like all right yeah from what I
remember at the time that we finished
the first movie and we were like in
development for the second movie the
recession was like hard-hitting and so a
lot of projects even like projects I had
auditioned for him whatever had just
fallen through about it so like I think
it was just like bad timing money and
then by the time like maybe they got
funding like we were all too old yes
dude like a clique grown up like in
college movie oh my god I want to do
like Claire Lyons takes New York well
because that's like nasty block like
working at some fashion company right
lay back in the day like movies like
that we're like okay but now it's like
it's cool to be different so like Claire
would be on top totally you were saying
that like 21 chapters yeah yeah yeah I
was dying by the way you guys like the
way that this all happened it's funny
so if
so no from inception K'Ehleyr wrote in
the morning toasters Facebook group when
we spoke about the movie The Clique
which we do often cuz it's a great film
I mean and she was loving she was like I
was in the movie and we're like wait and
I go does her Facebook page I'm like
that's cool air I was like truly you
don't understand I was I just quit like
I just had a job and I just quit and I
was like in line at Starbucks getting my
boss's coffee and you guys were like
Massie block I was like oh my god this
is my chance I like have to say
something I have to tell them so yeah
and if you're not in the toasters group
like what are you doing I couldn't agree
more
who do you know you brought some
behind-the-scenes photos that will roll
for you just some pics of the gals just
hanging out so it was odisha Kristen
Massey Dylan Dylan and Dylan aides own
food you were like Dylan I don't know
why I didn't I should I would have been
great in the movie you should have him
like that
maybe if we make a grown-up version and
I thought the blonde girl the one whose
mom thought she was a nerd but then she
like what changed
she was like good luck charlie
yeah Bridget oh my god bridget mendler
that's so crazy and Lily's was in it too
but she wasn't part of the core crew she
was like you guys I know you guys are
fans she's the coolest oh she was she
was literally you know tolerate and she
would be so nice and so cool and like
definitely I were just being a toaster
anything so gorgeous and like not what
you would expect she's kind of like
intimidating yang yeah and she's
literally like the nicest coolest girl
she also would have been good for Massie
yeah she's really great
yeah so when you went to go watch The
Clique last night where did you watch it
do you have it on DVD
girl we like couldn't find it it was
like under a pile of wood right a bunch
of crowd it's just like it's on Amazon
yeah I thought I recommended movies yeah
I Valeris I found the DVD we watched it
I like had two glasses of wine and I was
literally screaming the whole time like
great cuz what we were saying is my club
I watched it recently also with my god
it was so cringy like everything is like
painful to watch but when we were kids
like we loved it like that so he
actually spoke like most like me where I
used to do like a State of the Union
like I like school planner
yeah oh my god I'm so late it's so
embarrassing but we didn't have like
Instagram like these guys right thank
you so much more interesting now with
reischel media oh my god it scares me so
your singer you're an actress where can
people kind of keep up with with you and
all your work keep up with me and all my
work definitely Instagram is where the
actions at Ellen Marlow know at the end
right no it's a common mistake no at the
end
Ellen Marlow also my youtube channel
with my brother the Marloes and we post
videos of us singing very like Ryan and
Sharpay vibes yeah it's Barry and we
were very that in high school everyone
wanted to kill us like the fact everyone
wanted to kill you it was probably like
why you weren't Sharpay oh they were
anywhere it was kind of like Rachel
Berry like Sharpay Evans like I needed
to chill a little bit like everyone I
would click so you could wait what was
it like at school oh my god did everyone
like I was like mortified of this movie
for years and now I love it now I love
it
of course focus when I was in high
school like yeah
I got tech high school with like 3000
kids like I went to a giant public high
school in LA okay and like these kids
were just like oh my god that [ __ ]
that's in the movie like wait admit it
well like when like when it was
happening well when I left no I left
school to go film and like obviously all
my girlfriends were like shook be on
yeah like because at the time it shook a
big deal the movie oh my god and then
they had like an online contest for
girls to submit their auditions yeah
there was like a nationwide casting
where when I thought you got the part
no no no that's regular audition I like
went in too many many many auditions
yeah but it's so crazy it was something
else like the whole thing and honestly
like the funniest part of it all is like
an aunt and I do like mean this in a
very genuine genuine way the toast and
the toaster is like it really like
brings cool girls together like that's
like the power of it and then like
that's the magic of it all and like when
I posted that thing in the group I was
like okay like maybe 30 people will it's
nerve-wracking to post in the group
I wasn't that nervous but I was like no
one's actually like no one's really
gonna care like what I was like oh ho
its do it got like 1,300 likes or
something crazy like that and you guys
were like we want you on the show I was
like I can't believe it I was at work
and I was like I'm sorry I have to take
a day I literally inconsolable so if we
what's your day job I was for the past
six months I just quit like literally
this all happened at like a magical time
okay that toast and she quit I mean
honestly kind of I I was working as
executive assistant to the creative
director at Diane von Furstenberg that's
cool that's so cool
full Andy Sachs Styles oh it was it was
really fun I learned a lot I met a lot
of cool people I dress I love Diane like
I mean it's just an icon it's very cool
it happened to the show house of DVF
really no justice rate on it yeah I mean
I told my boss who's like this wild man
I was like we need our own like flipping
out yeah if Cosmo can get a show anyone
can get a show and house of DVF was good
they had cool girls on it I never I've
never seen it but like it's something
that like everyone's like not just is so
fun girl who won the final season was
dating bella thorns current boyfriend
that guy mad son before bella thorne
she's like I was head up she's so cool
Wow that's what I was doing it was that
really great I learned so much but I
kind of like I had to take a break from
the industry for like a hot second like
I've been doing it since I was nine so I
was like I need to go work and then now
I'm right back in we're full throttle
like we're going for it and I'm so happy
and this is a good last going thank you
for cutting down memory lane
it was truly wonderful so I was so happy
make sure you keep up with Ellen on her
Instagram at Ellen Marlow and her
YouTube the Marlo's but she's educating
this is the morning trust the Millennial
morning show we're live Monday to Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on Facebook and
YouTube so make sure you like us there
and then we're also available as a
podcast a little later in the day so
make sure you subscribe the podcast app
leave says five stars that how many the
most premium content have beautiful yarn
how many are singing horses are and stay
tuned to the podcast channel because our
interview with Joey King will be coming
up in a few days excited maybe you guys
so much we'll see you tomorrow bye
you